I mean haven't you ever noticed like
women even getting cheated on right yeah
you know most men can't cheat most but
it's just only the men that you see can
cheat so okay so women on dating apps we
swipe right five percent of the time
okay yeah so and women we think eighty
percent of men are ugly right so if
we're all if we all think 80 of men are
ugly who are we dating the same men yeah
correct so yeah right right so so if
heat could cheat your ex-boyfriend right
yeah no no shame I've been cheated onto
we yeah we all have we everybody has
yeah but but the whole point is that
like you picked someone that could yeah
when most guys can't meaning meaning in
a way he had multiple women and there
were signals that showed that that you
were attracted to it's not conscious
like most of the time we don't know why
we're doing what we do yeah but there's
a reason you like confidence confident
men tend to get laid Yeah Yeah